who's more compassionate the stern
father with boundaries who maybe isn't
the cool dad or the compassionate mom
who spoils the child only in this
instance we're not talking about the
most disastrous result being a petulant
toddler but we're talking about grown
lost adults finding themselves
exponentially more likely to end up in
prison depressed and part of a
demographic that lives up to a 40%
attempted suicide rate both pre and
post-ops
so question of the day these days of
course it's very common advice to be
healthy people want to be as they're
more health-conscious than ever and you
don't want to be injecting yourself with
copious amounts of unnatural hormone oh
why do you think that logic all of a
sudden goes out the window when it comes
to hormone replacement therapy for
transgenders and let's take the kids out
of the equation in puberty blockers
we've talked about that I'm just talking
about adults have you actually taken the
time to think of the toxic impact that
adding exogenously gene to the male body
could have let me know we don't really
talk about a lot we talk about what
people want what the societal
ramifications what about the potentially
early cancerous graves if you think
that's compassionate I think you're
sociopaths okay I know we got a lot of
we got a lot of a lot of heat as well as
a lot of a positive feedback for when
the transgenders attack video which we
didn't ask for now I am NOT the hero you
deserve a signal just a severed they
must need me and there's a fidget
spinner so for context for those who
missed it of course at the recent change
remind with the women's March that we
did I was assaulted by not one but two
counted two transgender clear
I sign
I'm sick and tired of this [ __ ]
debate men need to respect women period
piece of living garbage ass dumpster
fire
trash gum on the bottom of my shoe a
country we're guilty until proven
instance innocent rotting in a jail but
I when you take into account that only
0.6 percent of Americans identify as
transgender statistically being
assaulted by two it's like I hit the
mega ball crackpot it's unbelievable
this woman's March 0.6 percent of the
population committed 100 percent of the
felony it should be noted by the way
that the sample that has a margin of
error of plus or minus 0% also it's
entirely made up by me so it's very
reasonable yeah here's something else
that's important we actually sort of
looked into wider media coverage and I
want to get into the empirical obviously
some of the data that might surprise you
but it seems anecdotally at first I
think you probably know this but you
don't necessarily know how it correlates
with statistics it would seem that the
transgender population has been very
much over-represented in the realm of
public I believe the I believe the
clinical nomenclature here is public
meltdown childlike freakout
my points are guilty come on that's the
that is the true name of the female who
is demanding that other women eat from
wax his beautiful balls feminine
wonderful Harry Harry I'm in the parking
lot in the world with damn shoes back
today because any damn girl who comes up
in here but after me with it is an ass
on her [ __ ] back will be
respected and she will not be called a
good dancer you and your mama your
sister your brother no no no your bro
now no you're probably I reckon a
pronounced limp it's important that it's
a world out here stupid [ __ ] my my my
conclusion there is that those are some
very hormonal imbalance babe yes well I
know that anecdotally because these
stories happen all the time but what is
the empirical data tell us and I think
it's important we often hear right that
transgender individuals are they're more
likely to be the victim of violent
crimes but here's something important
that's what we hear about a lot not them
perpetrating the crimes most of these
reports they just list the number of
transgender individuals who've died
violent deaths at some point in the past
year so really actually as far as I
could tell it all stems from one
tracking study from one place I want to
read you the direct quote from Human
Rights Campaign net or go leftist
website into
thousand eight advocates tracked at
least 26 deaths of at least of trans
gender non-conforming people in the
United States due to fatal violence some
of these cases involve clear
anti-transgender bias well I would think
all of them would in others the victims
transgender status may have put them at
risk in other ways such as forcing them
into unemployment poverty homelessness
and/or survival sex work so of the 26
yes when you actually look at them cited
most of them have no relation to the
victims transgender status they could
have been killed in a carjacking or a
robbery but because they're trans it's
violence against the trans community
could if this has likely been violence
against the car possessing community or
as it's known yeah Detroit let's
contrast this with the hard numbers that
we have that are undeniable in relation
to transgenders being ones who commit
the crime so Lambda Legal a pro LGBT
legal organization they report that one
in six trans individuals have been in
prison oh my gosh now we do need to have
some scale here right some context well
let's compare that to the average
lifetime incarceration rate for sis men
commonly referred to once upon a time as
men it's one and nine and it's far
higher than for assists women which is
one in 56 one in six for transgender
individuals compared to one in 56 so see
ladies trans women they're just like you
knock knock who's there just a trans
male the female at your porta potti with
a one to six chance of committing a
serious crime big bad wolf huffing and
puffing and blowing the porta potti next
door the point is build your house out
of brick why would you do that of sex it
doesn't make any sense and that pig had
to carry the weight I think the other
one should have been eat another wolf
yeah take away is another means another
long-term study in Sweden they found
that transgender individuals were
increasingly likely to be convicted of
any crime including violent crime
specifically following sex reassignment
surgery now leftist would probably have
you believe that that's because the
entire police force are transphobic you
know suck don't shoot I understand that
here's the truth and this is even for
people who are the most progressive in
the world it doesn't stem from a place
of hate sometimes they get confused with
the gist of whether you're
perceived woman but then you snapped
them right back in line by demanding me
yeah the confusions of the fog lifts no
there's true she's ladylike so let's
let's throw a hypothesis here you know
I'm not even like I just want to pose a
question could could transgender
behavior that we see it possibly be
linked to the fact no one talks about
this that we're injecting these people
with unbelievable amounts of hormones
the long-terms effects of which we don't
really know and what we do know
definitively at this point is it is not
good yeah so to keep in mind that this
is something we talk about all the time
in society that that were warned about
injecting on natural hormones looking at
a current discourse around anabolic
steroids and sports right all kinds of
warnings and a lot of them are accurate
they can harm fertility psychological
well-being the list goes on and on and
on now let's look at the discussion
regarding hormones and chicken yeah in
milk they think we believe that young
women are getting their periods early
because of hormones in milk but then you
don't put the milk in the UK that people
even eat organic or they avoid BPA
plastic is because of what's referred to
as they often if you read any of these
mom green blogs they refer to them as
endo curring disruptors yeah often I
think the term is xenoestrogens and that
these chemicals allegedly mimic estrogen
in the body which when they are
basically provided in excess they're
believed to be cancerous
yeah now when it comes to changing
genders how about using the exact same
hormones injecting them directly or
taking them sublingually in a pill form
suddenly we're pushing them on kids and
there couldn't possibly be any health
risks because the science is up well you
know what actually that's not the case
we'll get into some more science but
first hit the notification bell hit all
notifications because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot and do subscribe
to the show on iTunes as well if you
haven't good join my club that's the
place where you can watch all of whom
should we be banned new videos every
weekday at 9:00 right let's get into
this the I think ester dean is someone
we should talk about in the psychiatric
program and does that relate to this
this statistically undeniable and
startling honestly the more I looked
into it violent behavior a few different
things well we can start with a estrogen
progesterone these are seen as feminine
warm
feminine hormones obviously men have
these hormones as well but in lower
amounts just like women have
testosterone but in lower amounts so
high progesterone has already been
linked to suicide right progesterone has
included quite a bit in male to female
transitioning therapies and we've
already talked about the 40-something
percent attempted suicide rate pre and
post-op for transgenders women already
have a higher rate of depressive
psychological disorders and men and
sometimes this is thought to be linked
to complicated obviously this is a
simplification right I'm not an
endocrinologist they're only a handful
of really good ones in the country but
it's often thought that it's linked to
the interactions of estrogen and in
female related hormones now we also know
that when people go off steroids there's
no arguing about this they can become
depressed they can become suicidal they
can become very moody often it could be
perceived as bipolar disorder and this
is something that is important again the
endo cream system is is so intricate and
complex and one hormonal signal or it
will affect another one and it's it's
really difficult to to sift through all
of it but they all do play a role a yin
and yang as it relates to other hormones
in the body so a good example of this is
the thyroid right a lot of people nose
who have hyper that every single fat
person out there uses that an excuse I
have a thyroid thing thyroid doesn't
make you 900 pounds yeah it doesn't put
you on a TLC show but I understand it
may help you may be holding some water
weight anyway you have an ice cream
thing yes I would think even ice cream
truck thing yeah it's kind of true so
the thyroid plays a big role in people's
emotions depression thyroid levels are
are dramatically affected by estrogen as
a matter of fact sometimes people with
thyroid disorders are misdiagnosed very
often as bipolar or as having some kind
of a psychiatric condition because they
manifest themselves the same way add on
top of that that male to female
transgender they face a out set of
hormones if you have kids
warning 35 percent drop in ability to
achieve or get by the way can anyone
here guess the orgasm rate for cisgender
men that's it's not a trick question
it's a hundred percent very easy to
please not to mention of course this is
really important
the connection between estrogen and and
breast cancer and women is well
established right if a woman has breast
cancer one of the first things they put
them on is up is I think it's um
anastrozole Arimidex it's an aromatase
inhibitor which prevents people from
converting certain hormones to estrogen
that's what a lot of bodybuilders take
or people who men who have naturally
high estrogen levels it's something that
prevents hormonal signals from
converting to estrogen that's one of the
first things they give to women with
breast cancer now here's something else
a lot of people don't know considering
that breast cancer is is is rare in men
but it does happen
it hasn't really been largely studied
but they have studied it more recently
and men with just high levels of
estrogen we're not some people who have
actually injected estrogen in trying to
become a woman we're talking about men
with slightly abnormally high levels of
estrogen they had a multiple increased
odds ratio of breast cancer over men who
had normal levels significant the same
thing applies by the way to other forms
of cancer prostate cancer it's the same
reason you go on any health blog that
people are drinking from Nalgene bottles
and that stupid awful swill bottle you
can't put ice cubes in I don't
understand to get yourself an old-school
classic Stanley thermos you
self-important affected prick so but we
get it we all see at the airport being
eco-friendly like I don't buy bottles of
water I'm the guy who commented on Chris
Pratt it's easier to clean you can put
ice in it
what are you European you don't want ice
in your water we're better than Europe
that's why we left we are behind you
again just average men with high
estradiol levels not people injecting it
directly into their ass or popping pills
I think it's important for people to
note here so we've talked about
psychiatric conditions we've talked
about the increased rate of cancer we
know that now is there a direct
correlation or causation with the one in
six chance of ending up in prison as
opposed to the one in 50 something for
women we don't know necessarily because
we haven't studied all this this is a
new frontier but what we do know is
definitive and it's not good so again
we're just posing a question here based
on the data that we have undeniable data
that shows us both male and female
transgenders are dramatically more
likely to commit serious crimes violent
or otherwise the somewhat speculative
again but cumulative data tells us that
attempting like you said you know to
alter the norm normal hormonal profile
yeah it not only dramatically increases
likelihood of cancer disease but also
serious mood is
and behavioral disorders which I don't
know why this is controversial
considering this Chris Benoit scenario
we're talking about it you've heard the
term roid rage right we know that
hormones affect behavior and they can
inflict behavioural damage on people so
could it be that all of these health
effects we know are connected to
hormones could possibly be contributing
to the unusually high level of
freak-outs that we have personally
encountered from transgender individuals
and this brings me to my biggest gripe
right here we do have to get going my
biggest gripe with the whole framing of
the LGBTQA AIP and a silent number-two
issue is specific and specifically the
hate speech policies of big tech and the
DNC is that it presumes that only the
left has compassion for these
individuals
but if simply encouraging people to do
whatever feels right and to live their
truth whatever the hell that means you
rube can objectively and if it's
something that can objectively and
undeniably cause irreparable damage I
is that really compassion let me ask
what's more compassionate the stern
father with boundaries who maybe isn't
the cool dad or the compassionate mom
who spoils the child only in this
instance we're not talking about the
most disastrous result being a petulant
toddler but we're talking about grown
lost adults finding themselves
exponentially more likely to end up in
prison depressed and part of a
demographic that lives up to a 40%
attempted suicide rate both pre and
post-ops so it may be a question that's
uncomfortable but maybe this world you
that's being pressed out there is
progress isn't so compassionate after
all hey there YouTube viewer subscribe
to the channel hit the notification bell
if you're already subscribed to this
channel because that lets you know when
new videos come out and they don't show
up on the youtube search feed also there
are videos playing in boxes here click
one of those just of all the things that
I just mentioned all you have to do is
one and if you don't I will run for the
United States presidency under the
1/1000 64% Cherokee party I have yet to
pick my VP